three months on estrogen today
so that's a before picture and after
picture
when i first saw it i actually thought
it was a a female
what i found very interesting was when
certain verses were presented
the individual was saying yeah but i
don't see it like that
when you were six months of estrogen
subhanallah you're glorifying allah
check out our sponsors nature's blends
they specialize in premium ethiopian
black seed products
their products are fantastic health
supplements and also from the sunnah
the website is in the description link
below you can also use the discount code
salaam 10 for 10 of their products
brothers and sisters and dear friends
welcome to another episode of smile to
general
welcome to adidas channel uh robin's
sister so we've got obviously sean
did that with a rewind selector nothing
okay so we've got we're gonna be
reacting today to something that
i've been mean i wouldn't tell meanings
i thought it would be interesting but
we're going to find out what inspired me
to do it so let me get straight into it
here so this is
the instagram of the person
the trans hijabi yeah okay so
this person i'm gonna just call a person
because by the way guys he she is
he legally sashi but i'm not gonna get
into it so if we say
he or she i don't wanna get into it okay
let's just get
on with it here okay i got a message
from uh this
person um about i think last year yeah
now we checked the messages it was
deleted so maybe i didn't want to see it
so maybe you were lying
[Laughter]
i think i'll comment what it was but
they were asking a question on a
specific thing
and i did try to give them some kind of
advice i don't know what it was but
let's get straight into here so this is
three months on estrogen today so that's
a before picture
and after picture when i first saw it i
actually thought it was a
a female in the context of biologically
yeah
now you can see here it says okay i
haven't posted on here in a while but i
thought i'd share some
i'll share this big milestone with you
all being able to transition has been
one of the biggest blessings allah has
granted me and i thank them every day
for it unfortunately my story isn't the
same as the majority of transgender
youth who are waiting until they
turn 18 to be able to access gender
affirming health care
okay so she's you 17 yeah
wow for um
20 25 imagine if you were stabbed and
someone told you that you had to wait
until you're 18 to get stitched up
because your parents won't consent this
shouldn't be happening not in this day
and age
too many lives have been lost over
something so preventable
we must hashtag liberate trans youth
okay
look before we start comparing the trans
thing to gain stabbed
yes and not only that look what we're
going to do today is
if there's anybody that's transgender
homosexual um or want to identify their
self as
whatever yeah i mean i'm amazing
whatever you want to be
whatever inanimate objects wherever you
want to be okay we're not here
to mock but we're here to educate and
learn and we're going to put some
lines to boundaries that we can't cross
yeah now
how do you feel when it says this very
statement being able to transition has
been one of the biggest blessings allah
has granted me
as a muslim and she's this person is
muslim as well
how do you feel when they're saying that
this is a blessing from allah they're
praising allah
for something that we would say
islamically is actually an
open sin seems uh it's a bit confusing
the first question is like it seems
contradictory to the fundamental
teachings of islam
and i'd wonder why or what basis
they're considering it a blessing
exactly now
what you just said there are you
attacking not abusing are you just
stating something that islamically
affect
i think i'm abusing them
i'm just really targeting them with hate
but obviously i'm not attacking them i'm
just i'm speaking factually like
islam has its own doctrines good so we
want to make something very clear when
we're pointing at these facts guys
you need to understand they've got three
thousand what this person's got three
thousand one hundred eighty one comments
and i'm sure a lot of it is hate we're
not here to do that we're just here
trying to disparage and just understand
really disparage you and
put you trying to understand so let's
let's scroll up now yep so that was what
they say three months on estrogen today
yeah
um that is a change massive change okay
here i think that is that this person
happy prior to my federal quest remember
who you
who got wherever you're right here okay
let's move to that i'm not sure
product does that say project protect
protect black trans woman
okay okay this is a picture of this
person yeah
yes in in in in a female what's what
should welcome
okay next picture
if you first saw this would you be like
that's a man
like biologically no
no okay the second picture i'll be like
yeah
there's something i'm trying to say yeah
okay no problem let's let's carry on
let's go up inshallah and this is
another picture of themself and another
picture
so the features get less and less
obvious
yes second picture
third picture like if you spotted
something on the ground i'll be honest
like
some brothers might see this as fitnah
some girls might be like yo
you get that you know i'd be thinking
yeah i'd be like what is she looking at
on the floor because that looks really
interesting
like it's what's that on the floor
nice yeah so okay
now six months so we saw three months
this is six months yeah okay um on
estrogen japan
and and you when you were six months of
allah estrogen this is what we really
need to understand here so the the the
the
person that's watching this yeah um
trans hijabi
you're glorifying allah and this is
where there's a thin line because you
know there was a sahabi of the
the prophet sallallahu salaam you should
drink alco all the time and used to get
flogged all the time yeah
okay and the flocking obviously differs
yeah as far as
said that the flocking should be 80
lashes if i'm not mistaken the reason
why he said is 80
and this was for a drunk person because
they said the person who's drunk is more
likely to slander so he equated
he he made this uh the flogging 80 which
is the same for flogging yeah
for slander because he said a person
who's drunk is most likely to make up
lies
okay yeah i find it very interesting
yeah but the thing is this hobby was
getting flocked yeah
and one time the sahabah said you know
what kind of like the person you're the
listener
and you're you're drunk so panel they
might run they said may allah curse you
and what did the prophet sallam say you
know
okay um the processor said don't say
that
he loves allah and his messenger now
this is very interesting now we can put
this
maybe in that kind of category because
drinking alcohol is a major sin
to change your gender i'm not scared to
say it's a major mindset i don't know
might be in the major category i don't
know being homosexual
is in the major side of things yeah of
course being homosexual and knowing that
the act in itself you believe it's wrong
is a good thing because at least you you
say look i know it's wrong
weakness or whatever yeah then to say no
it is because when you say it is
on the verge of to say subhanallah
how would you like like it's it's such a
thin line because people are attacking
them we don't know
i'm going to be honest i'm not going to
be disrespectful yeah it's me just being
honest
just genuinely i i i see a like
it's an insult like an insult to the
religion okay do you think
this person is doing it as an insult i
don't think they are
i don't think they're doing it as an
insult but somebody that
knows basic rulings of islam knows
it's it's like it's like a vegetarian
that eating a burger and saying eating a
burger alhamdulillah
yeah but somebody that is a vegetarian
okay all right
let's let's make let's make this person
yeah and
why do i'm calling person i'm not saying
i've disrespected because i don't think
he's true he's a neutral
yeah exactly i'm just trying to see a
person out of respect right this person
needs to answer if you're watching this
yeah please understand that imagine if i
was drinking alcohol and i said
i'm drinking alcohol alhamdulillah
that's a better example than my one i'm
actually quite upset
that i didn't come up with that i've got
good analogies
so just understand where we're coming
from yeah that's where we'll come from
so once again
to spread hate and things okay now this
is a video this is a video
it's a video here let's watch the video
i like video how can was the video
because it's on
airplane mode oh of course it is
[Music]
[Music]
okay i think that's a goodness here in
the context of she's saying look the
prophet salallahu
went to the time he was stoned so much
that he was bleeding from up to his
uh sandals yeah now do you think
islamically this person should be
insulted attacked mocked ridiculed
um do you think i'm just saying if the
prophet salallahu was here today
and he saw this person yeah would the
prophet insult her
no would he attack no okay
wouldn't the process say okay look like
the boy who came and said oh mr allah
make
allow me to come in what are you talking
about
the process never ever that was in his
character
we're not so sinner one he then gave an
analogy that changed his
his perception of the whole exactly and
that's what we're trying to do
with this person yeah we're trying to
say look understand where we're coming
from
because our religion is dear you're a
muslim we don't have it and by the way
they are born after there was a river
they were born muslim yeah yeah
pakistani or something like that
apparently yeah okay so the thing is
here that you need to understand
we find it a little bit insulting when
you say stuff like oh i'm
i've transgendered allah or subhanallah
because
it just shows that you unless you're
saying
that you have there's no evidence from
quran sunnah
if you are saying there is evidence to
what you are doing
then this is outright misguidance it can
even be going down to the root of coffer
yeah so what we would say is
is to have a balance let's balance be
balanced here
what you're doing is wrong except that
it is wrong it is it's the same as me
committing having a girlfriend i have to
admit it is wrong
drinking alcohol it is wrong even though
i can come and say look i'm a man
i'm like this i have the urge i can't
help myself i can't help myself
you can't tell me to you know i can't
help myself yet the point is this
you can't help yourself okay no problem
but except that it is wrong
and then to say subhanallah i've got a
girlfriend
imagine if i said yeah alhamdulillah you
know i drink alhamdulillah
it's an insult to the religion because
you actually
you're you're you're in it's you're
insulting it's as if you're insulting
allah
i'm trying to say even though you don't
mean to but it comes across like that so
what would you say i i i i noticed one
thing
when when they were on the mohammed dija
podcast and he brought up certain verses
so oh by the way so muhammad hijab
actually interviewed
yeah this person yeah that's gonna be on
his channel you you guys need to watch
that it's uh
yeah it's difficult it was very
respectful it was
it was an interesting um discussion
thanks for that
that's that's what i needed that's
that's what this discussion was missing
so yeah but um what i found very
interesting was when certain verses were
presented
the individual was saying yeah but i
don't see it like that
yeah but i think god i don't see god to
be like this that he would do this this
so there it is
it felt like it was a lot of subjective
interpretation
and hijab presented a um it was it was a
very nice translation
of uh surah 3 i think ayah 4
where it says certain verses of the
quran are
clear yes and there are see some that
are not
exactly and then um yeah certain people
interpret
the declared verses and obviously i'm
paraphrasing but that
and i thought that was very profound and
i think even to that point that you're
saying
uh people can say yeah but i don't see
it to be this but
that's the thing though exactly you're
putting your desires you're putting your
understanding you're
limited because this individual is only
17. yeah
yeah and wow i didn't know that they
looked that young
so i i think it's it's and hijab ended
in a very nice way where he was like
look
just just take this and just reflect on
it we're not here to attack we're not
here to do this
but look it's very important to
understand that the quran is there for a
reason we have a 14
you know 100 year tradition
which has be which has sciences
encapsulating and preserving
narrations and and we have entire
sciences behind it you can't just get
somebody coming and saying
yeah that's misguidance the biggest form
of miscarriage if
someone says i we us me i think we think
the biggest one misguided is that and
okay
let's just go for it
okay why are you turning it down
so turn up the music yeah so
and there's another picture here
yeah so that's the last picture
i don't know what this what's that
difficult what's it say yes ah
the core order okay so here we go so
this is the gender of
my the of the minor it changed to female
yeah so look look even look it's very
important here
the fact that islamically where do we
where do we stand with this yeah okay
even islamically
yeah okay even islamically
the very certificate that you're holding
yeah our um
it's so hard no it's very hard i don't
say dear person
islamically dear brother islamically
yeah that what you're holding
certificate himself is an evidence to
save that it says that what does it say
let's read it
this person has changed change the this
gen
this gender of the minor has changed the
female
so your hustle is what you're a male 1
now
i'm not going to go back and forth and
because i think it won't be productive
yeah if you say you you feel like a
female i can't do nothing about that you
know
you can't so the thing is here is anyone
out there that's transgender
have these kind of tendencies it's very
very important brother sisters to
understand
that all of us are born with different
tendencies
like in the context of like we are
entrapped within our fore and we speak
to certain psychology and they see the
it in your head you need to separate
that sometimes you think that thought
within yourself it's you
it's not but all of us get certain
thoughts in our head we're like i want
to be live
how did that go into my head so we need
to divorce ourselves with that thought
in there because yeah we are not our
thoughts yes this is what brother said
him
i mean i bless him to ski i might ask
you guys to check it out
i said that so i think i should get that
you know
you need to divorce it because the thing
is if you cater to everything that goes
in your head
you're going to be in places subhanallah
because every foot in your head if you
get it you're going to think okay
yeah okay oh no i saw this brother i
think he's handsome oh i'm gay
oh my gosh i'm okay no brother you're
not gay bro it's okay you know if you
think that brother
is i don't know handsome or whatever it
doesn't make you gay some people confuse
you message me
i'm getting i'm like it's not blind
because it's in drool in our head
so i probably saw my profile and they're
like man this happens
this guy looks yeah this guy looks good
frankly you don't know that
and that's what it is man like what
advice would you give
uh to this to this or anybody that has
gone through the transition i think you
started a
very interesting kind of point um
it makes a nice change for once uh
the point was that everybody is going
through desires yeah some people are
trying to give up
um certain dietary requirements like
like sugars and and
i don't know lactose or whatever maybe
some people they're heavily
you know attracted to the opposite
gender some people
are uh heavy yeah they're they're
attracted to adrenaline yeah adrenaline
junkies or whatnot
and yeah and certain things that the
things and games console
yeah but but you're right in saying that
if if you indulge in every single desire
it's not going to be productive so you
rather than putting your kind of or what
what should i indulge in
yes yeah rather than letting society
dictate that which constantly morphs and
changes
and it's got political and all sorts of
influences
why not allow an objective um
individual somebody that's created you
somebody that has the picture
when we have the pixel and then you will
be truly free
yeah and and everybody's fighting
against something exactly
exactly you know that's ours i'm reading
a new book it's called beauty sick
it's very interesting it's called beauty
sick like women that are actually sick
they're they're beauty sick and there's
this woman who's
got a phd um and she's actually writing
about
how 90 of women are not happy with one
part of their body
one another yeah and it's mad
it's it's an pandemic but it's literally
a pandemic
it is unbelievable that women are
subjugated and i believe that's one of
the reasons why a lot of them come to
islam
the the enslavement to the the the
the beauty industry is unbelievable bro
it's crazy
so what we're just saying is to our dear
friend brothers and sisters
you're a muslim look we know look i'll
be honest do i doubt as a transit driver
you don't have allan is messenger i'll
be honest
deep down i know you love allah's
messenger i i i can assume the best and
say i know you love allah's messenger
what you're doing is a sin i'm so sorry
you can go
if you say to me ali will hang you maybe
out of compulsion i might get myself out
of it but i might just say look i'm
sorry it's a sin even if you kill me
so the thing is i would say is to
acknowledge and be a bit more sensitive
because just the way you're saying this
is my right this is how i feel
i feel like a female we're saying we're
muslims we love our lines messenger so
do you
so when you say feeling is fine just
please don't change the religion you
know yes
so that's what we're saying look if
you're going to go down that route that
is between you and your lord one of
their judgment you can
we're not saying what you're doing is
disbelief unless you're saying that
you there's evidence to it yeah
say no so please inshallah please bear
that in mind
and anybody that's watching i hope this
was fruitful um
and for those who thought that we're
gonna mock this person we're not here to
mock oh
man yes and we wouldn't completely waste
a video then isn't it
it's already pointless yeah
but brothers and sisters that's it from
me and lee uh
check out my jobs interview with him i'm
actually looking forward to myself man i
got a bit late when i was at the end
but it'll be nice to watch that
inshallah and let's see what they had to
say
uh and if their beliefs um if they
accept
like if they accept that it's a sin or
not it's gonna be very interesting i
love the etiquette that took place
they they had respect it was hijab yeah
and but hijab didn't compromise a lot of
mistake that some people do
when they speak with people with
deferring opinions they start
compromising the
core principles of islam and that's what
i liked about that
and that's why you guys should subscribe
to smile to jannah you know
brother sisters till next time
and don't forget to check that interview
yeah definitely
thought i would rewind no hats no
trainers
you